oh you gotta love small towns everyone
gets along so well so here we go
continuing with the journey through
series one of broadchurch so so far I am
enjoying the progression of this however
I'm also seeing some potential stumbling
blocks at least as far as my own
personal tastes which I'm gonna have
probably have to preface every step of
this way every time that I bring up
something that I would prefer the show
not do because I know other people will
say oh but that's the best part and I'm
sure for you it is for me it won't be if
it happens what you probably will well
good well get there though but as I said
the the pace at which everything is
unfolding is pretty good so we're each
well I say each episode I'm only two
episodes eight so if they keep this pace
it'll be a good way to do it so because
we got a few more details a few more
wrinkles a few more leads and while at
the same time getting a little more time
with the family to see how it's
impacting them spending a little more
time with the cops and getting sort of a
better sense of this town as a whole
because I doubt pretty pretty early on
into the first episode that this was
going to be a story about a community as
much as it was about a crime or even the
family that that crime impacted so it
does seem to be balancing where to put
time really well which is good I'm stuck
even though she gave the monkey to
Danny's sister I'm still I've got my own
in that reporter I'm like I owe the
psychic was an odd addition and I'm
really curious as to whether that's
gonna show up again and be a recurring
element in the show and how that'll play
out or if that's just gonna basically
drop a hint in regards to Tennant and
his characters damage that's gonna be
pulled upon later
I don't know but obviously I'm also
gonna call the the father absolutely did
not did it because we're two episodes
into an 18 episode series there's no way
that they're on to you know what is this
going on or if he's in any way involved
there's way more to it than that
I am gonna make the call that spoilers I
did you should know that I am gonna make
the call that Danny's dad is gay and
what he was doing was hooking up with
you no he said he was hooking up with a
friend who he's doesn't remember the
name of I'm sure he was hooking up with
a friend who quite possibly he never
knew the name of depending on how they
found each other that's my guess for him
we'll see where things go from there I'm
very nervous that what word that the
background we're gonna get on Danny's
gonna involve just kid sex stuff or kid
porn creation stuff that's just a gut
instinct like I I don't want it to and
not like I'm saying how dare you make a
story you know that involves that I mean
it's not a moral panic issue for me it's
just that's the first place my head went
and I almost feel like it's it's the
most obvious thing because I'm just I'm
looking at the way his friend is
behaving and you know and my first
logical thought on that is they were
both involved in something what could it
be and that's where my head leaves you
for you know kids at that age it could
be something else I hope it's something
else like that whole notion would just
kind of skeeve me in general like in a
way I really kind of don't want to be
skeeved right now but I will see as it
goes along the fun thing is because I'm
pre recording all this well before they
go up because I'm doing this so that I
can have content while I'm on vacation I
don't have to worry about you folks
spoiling stuff for me in the comments on
any given episode so if I'm right here
if I'm wrong you know talk all you like
in the comments it won't matter well
now I say that don't don't don't get
overly enthusiastic what the just cause
I mean I don't know if other people
watching this and going in the comments
will have seen the whole series I'm
dwelling on this too much so what else
is there
I'm finding it interesting I think the
moment that was like a really good
crystallizing moment was the family
handing over a list of people who they
thought might have killed Danny and
[Music]
Coleman she or she her character looks
at it and she just goes well these are
your friends are like yeah we know and I
think it's gonna be interesting to watch
how this depicts you know an event like
this turning relationships on their head
and just turning dynamics on their heads
because there's I'm not gonna say
there's no reason for niceties but the
desire for answers is gonna completely
override social niceties for this family
if nobody else and also I think they're
doing a really good job of showing the
pain for Jodie Whittaker especially
because like I I totally get her wanting
to get out of that house and just do
something do anything to feel some
semblance of normal so she tries to go
shopping but every look that she gets
from another human being just reinforces
to her that it's not normal and what it
was that happened you know and and I'm
not gonna go so far as to say she's
trying to move on I don't Lee she is but
she's trying to cope and something that
would help her cope would be some vague
sense of normalcy or at least a short
stretch of time that doesn't remind her
of what it is she's having to cope with
and she doesn't seem to be able to get
that I think the least right now at
least for me the least interesting sort
of thread that I expected to be is a red
herring but as is the the sister having
the boyfriend
and him being involved with the coke the
cocaine I just that I I'm calling right
now that that's a dead end and that's a
red herring and I don't find her or him
or that whole dynamic interesting enough
to care
so like that I'm kind of on I'm kind of
like yeah that's not what I'm nervous
about because I made reference to this
at the start of the app started the the
review the main thing that I'm worried
about is how much is gonna get devoted
to Tennant and whatever caused his issue
I will fully admit that I am intrigued
about whatever it is is is in his
backstory that is getting reference to
you know whatever his previous case was
that that's gotten mentioned a few times
however by and large I always find
detective stories to be much more
effective and interesting at least for
me and for my sensibilities when it's
about their work as opposed to who they
are as people
you know I I'll just I'll be blunt about
it I would rather watch you know Columbo
than Luther I'd rather see something
that's about them unraveling the mystery
then about this person who happens to be
solving a mystery so and again that's
just my preference but it doesn't really
feel like they're setting up really
digging into him and his damage and that
kind of reminds me of something like
insomnia which I actually kind of like
the the American version of it's pretty
decent I really didn't like the original
of that which I actually saw a long
before Nolan we made it but I get
worried about that where it's where it's
all this focus on this damaged detective
to the point that you kind of forget
what the supposed mystery even was so I
worry about the amount of emphasis that
I expect to be put on that I don't think
the show will lose the thread by doing
that it's just not an area that I'm
gonna find particularly interesting
because I
find him as a character most interesting
when he's just being the outsider
they're forcing somebody like Coleman's
character to have to look at her friends
in neighbors in ways that she doesn't
ever want to have to look at them but
he's gonna make her do it because this
is the job that's where I find him
interesting that's the dynamic I find
interesting whenever they do the slow
lingering shots of just him and his
vision goes blurry or whatever I'm
because I kind of I kind of zone out a
little bit if I'm being completely
honest so that's sort of where I am it's
it's still moving pretty well like I
said nothing's gone wrong it's holding
my interest just fine I am like I said
I'm seeing the things that I am afraid
about how much time is gonna get to vote
to the later but right now two episodes
in the balancing of elements the amount
of time given to each really well
handled really well put together really
well balanced we'll see if that holds
and that'll do it for my thoughts on
broadchurch episode two have you seen it
what are your thoughts about it whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do such as support me on
patreon like subscribe links for all
that stuff and more things even that I
didn't mention it's down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]